speaking of asian guys who sing jin i
had no idea you're so talented seriously
like i just scrolled through happened to
come across uh
instagram posts of you playing first
first off i had no idea you played a
and you know you played b i didn't know
you played so well and c i had no idea
you could sing so well thank you
mm-hmm that's very sweet very sweet of
you
yeah he can sing man you guys ready to
start yeah let's do it all right
double check double check double shot
mike's a professional
not in many things but at this yes i
have good news and bad news good news is
mike is here
all right mike catherine is here good
news for some yes great news for
mainly everybody bad news is brian
passed away
he passed away he had a good run the
corona caught up with him he had a good
53.
yeah no brian's on vacation in utah and
left me to
at the helm of the battleship he he this
is this is brian call a nutshell
friday after the show he goes hey dude
gone all next week
that's it ah that's it i'm like wait
what
he said gun all next week man so figure
it out i'm like
all right dude all right i will say
that's the big
there there was so many downsides like
but there was the big upside to working
like having drew dr drew as your partner
it was like your
your one and two punch when you're doing
a radio show
was that if drew had to do something
like that
it was 400 apologies
his manager trying to line up someone
else like a a greeting card coming in
the mail
like he's just such a nebulous overly
worried
you you and dr drew worked how long
together
about a decade yeah a while yeah and and
that's
that's love line the radio show and then
two tv shows and another a.m
like political talk show i mean you guys
have to be close
we're really close right brian's my best
friend so he gets a pass
yeah if we were just business partners
we wouldn't have made it this far
and honestly it doesn't work
forever if you're if you're not friendly
like even like the super talents of like
uh
um francesa and mad dog they're
they're as good as they come in sports
talk and they just couldn't sustain it
because they could they did not like it
open anthony the best
yeah especially like opie
as far as just like x's and o's doing it
getting the interest in keeping the flow
going opie's
really really good anthony is like super
talent like he's a [ __ ] freaking
nature
super talent and they couldn't sustain
it man and even with jim there too and
jim's another like
home run dude jim norton's as talented
as they get too he's awesome but you can
see why like big bands break up after a
while
dude once you get like first off like
artistically
doing something together artistically uh
collaboratively
is hard then you throw in the business
aspect of it
it's almost impossible i can't believe
people do it at all like i can't believe
there's any level of success rate
agree i think for brian and i was like
when we first started like i had
fighting but then this was also like my
baby this is
all i had but it was based off you to
give credit all the credit to brian's
based off brian's idea
where i was fighting just moved to l.a
he goes hey let's do
or he goes out of the brian callan show
has 14 listeners come on there
we go on there we have this weird
chemistry we didn't know each other that
well we had this weird chemistry goes
dude we should do this every week
i didn't want to do it and then i
committed to it
and then i was like if i'm in dude i'm
in we're doing it and he's like all
right i'll see you every thursday
so then we started doing it and then
became like my thing like i loved it i
was obsessed with it
and but brian had all this other stuff
going on you know he's acting
his stand up he's doing the 10 minute
podcast he has all this other stuff
going on
but this was my thing yeah you know so
then it became like i
ca i at first had resentment towards him
because
i was like dude why don't you care about
this as much as i do and he's like and i
get it you know
especially when i was younger you know
he's like why do i have
all this other [ __ ] going on man like
this is whatever he does now though
he may not say that to you but like
we've had conversations uh off the air
just brian about firing the kid
oh yeah different i mean now it's like
it's it's his baby yeah
i think uh for both of you i think for
any
man or woman who makes a living doing
stand-up that's always your
your passion your number one passion but
i think as far as like
professional priorities i still think
this has
got to be brian's number one right now
yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah
and it's just uh you know especially
when we first started it was just like
you know it was like i cared so much but
he had everything going on and then
you know you go through ups and downs
man but if we weren't best friends
there's no
way dude yeah there's no way yeah i i
mean
drew and drew and i are the same way i
like it
and i i had a hard thing coming into it
because like filling
coral issues is not it's just not
possible it's impossible and so i
i struggled so hard both professionally
and personally with drew trying to be
adam jr and i couldn't do it and and it
wasn't until like
six months a year in where i was like
look like
adam's michael jordan yeah i can be
let me be bj armstrong yeah i could it
doesn't mean
it doesn't mean i'm shitty no it just
means like i'm not going to be the next
different
mj like different tools yeah so but you
bring your own settings and um
and uh drew and i got
when we got personally close like to the
point where
our relationship mattered much more than
the show yes
that's when things just it just became
it honestly it became like
like uh cruise control you know to do to
do
content you know whatever that's how
this for me and brian like we never
we've never once like there's no
you guys know this there's no
pre-production like there's just we
don't
get like talk about we let's talk about
this never yeah you know
never and i i don't think you have to be
legitimate like like best friends like
drew and i
you know we we go hang out we we we go
to dinner with our families we like your
families
we go pump iron together and we like
hang out like drew and i seek each other
out to spend our personal time
he's also a great guy to have a best
friend like even
even for me i remember he was going to
come on here
maybe we were going to do some show
together and he couldn't do it
and he said he called left a voicemail
which nobody does anymore left this long
voicemail
and then sent like three texts
explaining why he couldn't i was like
dude i i
swear man it's all good like he's that
guy and he's like i'll make it i get
i'll make it up to you again
and then obviously came back on he's
super like
drew obviously is an entertainer he
makes a living as an
entertainer he's a hollywood dude but
because
his dna is a physician so he doesn't
handle things the same way like an
entertainer does like everything's about
like
i'm so so i let you down you're like
oh my god dude now it's getting
suspicious what do you need man
what do you need money dr drew why you
being so friendly man
and i you know and also i think like
once i started i had a real insecurity
about
like not what do i add to
a show sitting next to drew what do i
add
to his life personally and because
he's so smart he's so cool he's so buff
and he's so handsome all the people
love he's got this this kind of id thing
going on where i look at him and he's
kind of like a tyler durden version of
me
as the as the edward norton character
yes and then i realized i was like
oh what i provide him is actually pretty
substantial i
give him a total pass to be
a boneheaded 14 year old dude and talk
about
[ __ ] and van halen yeah and he he
needs he really i realized like he
actually really likes that a bit and i
was like you smell my fart you know
you guys are great for each other is it
is it classy is it tasteful
probably not but like there was value
there yeah hell yeah there's value there
yeah
i love dr drew man now look at you guys
yeah i love corolla too yeah there's
just i don't know man
these guys are doing the goddamn thing
we're gonna try and get them on here but
last minute
kind of replacement yeah no and uh of
course i got another
uh text this morning because you hit me
up about
coming on and filling in for brian and i
was like yeah you know we talked about
potential guests and i threw out names
of like
just my favorite people that i know live
in l.a great guests and so obviously you
know
like like a mccall and and jason ellis
was the first guy that came to my mind
i haven't seen jason forever and i love
jason you know he he would have been
here in a second it's just he has radio
right now so um but then of course you
know drew's name came out and
so i asked him and uh his his exact
response was
oh [ __ ] uh maybe i shouldn't be saying
this out loud because you know he's so
buttoned up but yeah he was like oh [ __ ]
okay give me a second
and he wrote me back he's like i have to
pod do my pod at
your mom's house um with with tom and
christina he's like i have to do
that exact time and then i got another
message this morning he's like i'm so
sorry i would have loved to come out
to you guys and he's such a good dude
man
yeah i think uh it just yeah i can't i
can't imagine like the you know
obviously you and dr drew are a great
team there's just certain there's like
teams man
you know yeah because it bums me out
like when you hear certain like guys
that hate each other or like
i heard i think was it metallica for a
long time they wouldn't
talk to each other yeah they would just
get like backstage they were in their
own dressing rooms they didn't
they would rehearse like hours before
but they didn't talk to the rehearsal
then they'd hit the stage and that
that's it man then they go they
[ __ ] hated each other i just got to
be hard i think that's metallica
i'm not going to sit here and pretend
like
i know the guys in metallica no means
like if they saw me they'd be like
hey mike how are you doing great but i i
know the security guy because
i've been so lucky to you know all the
luxuries that came with working at k
rock
for so long that i have spent time
with different members of metallica and
i will tell you that like
what makes them
one of the greatest rock and roll bands
of all time hands down
the the the kind of the trailblazers of
american metal
but also like they will it forever be
known as one of the greatest
rock bands of all time is um also what
makes it probably very hard to be in
metallica and that is lars
is a [ __ ] task master like lars lars
is a no-nonsense does not [ __ ] he does
not suffer fools like
he is a no [ __ ] and um well he would
fire brian
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes yes he's
not large but
yeah yeah you know what's weird i've
heard he's kind of
he's the captain of the ship right yeah
and maybe not musically but as far as
like getting [ __ ] done
there's no and you and by the way not
even just from watching the documentary
and
things like that and i'm a big fan
obviously i know kind of like behind the
scenes and [ __ ]
but if you just hang out with any
members of the band and like some of
this
some of the uh management and stuff like
it it's very clear
it's like yeah you need those guys
though otherwise you're all giving me a
bunch of fuck-ups you're probably not
gonna get where you need to go in life
with your band yeah i'll tell you what's
interesting is homeboy on the right
uh james hatfield james uh yeah hipfield
came on rogan
he talked about bees for about 90
minutes i was i was brokenhearted
and [ __ ] your bees let's talk about some
[ __ ] rock
stories dude well the thing is like dude
let me just talk about these
i think he's a really important figure
because oh my god
he is he really is like the animal
representation of metallica especially
after cliff died
catfield especially like the 86
headfield with the long [ __ ] hair and
the no
no beard just like he looked like a lion
look at him he'd hold that [ __ ]
explorer body
as he's become you know a grown man he
sits back and he'll talk openly about
like
how [ __ ] up his childhood was and how
[ __ ] angry and how
sad and how empty he felt and uh i think
that's really important because
to so many like macho dudes around the
world james hetfield's
like your icon you know and it's like
it's nice to see be like
oh you feel that way you're not
impenetrable you know you're like a
fraud too yeah
that's cool man yeah it's isn't it weird
now that you have
kids to think about the way like you
hear certain people the way they're
raised you have kids like ah [ __ ] dude
it's um it's heartbreaking um there's a
there's a very speaking of like talented
radio dude there's a very um
amazing sports radio duo based out of
los angeles but they're national
petros and money and matt money smith
of pedro some money used to be he used
to be the the
uh sports guy for kevin and bean the
radio show that i work for
and um he this is probably like y'all
know 2005-ish or something and you do
you guys remember the movie mystic river
that came out there you betcha
sweetheart yeah
great film and sean penn's awesome in it
uh tim robbins
it's a really really good film and uh i
was probably like 25 or something i
didn't know [ __ ] from [ __ ] and i go see
the movie and i come back to work
uh after the weekend and i was like
money gotta go see mystic river he's
like
do it i'm like why dude you know i can't
watch a movie like that i got children
and i go well dude it's it's a [ __ ]
movie what do you mean you can't he's
like no i gotta go watch a movie about a
dead daughter like i say and then at the
time i was like
what a [ __ ] dumb kids i know ten
years later i was like
oh i totally get it i totally get that
you know i'll watch like
even just like channel surfing i'll see
like forensic files as soon as it's like
and then they found
a six-year-old girl's body i'm like nope
i can't do it i can't do it now i can't
do any of that
yeah i totally didn't get it back then
i'll never forget that when the money
because i i was like
internally he's a really good guy so i
didn't want to say anything but
internally i was like what
it's a [ __ ] movie stop it just
divorce yourself from it no now i get it
none of that lovely bones with uh mark
wahlberg
[ __ ] yeah oh dude that i believe that
was kids you watched that you're like
[ __ ]
dude oh that was winter's bone i was
gonna say i thought that was our first
exposure to jennifer lawrence because i
remember watching winter's bone
and i was like i have a winter's bone in
my [ __ ] levites
i didn't know what a jennifer lawrence
was and i saw that i was like
hello there i don't think i've ever seen
it
it's all right no there's certain
there's certain yeah when you have kids
man there's just certain [ __ ] you can't
do
nah i haven't seen that movie well it's
like even like
uh on showtime that out their new
documentary outcry yeah
have you seen it no but you you were
talking about it last time and i'm
telling you i don't know if i could do
it man it's like well
yeah i guess the the story the narrative
isn't so much about
the kids getting molested that's a
byproduct unfortunately it's about
how the judicial system in austin texas
kind of [ __ ] this kid over
and bad cops and the bad judicial system
but um you know when they're talking
about you see a four-year-old and my
son's four and he's talking about what
this guy did to him you're like what the
i started over analyzing everybody my
son comes in contact with yep
from drop off at school and everything
you just started going through all of it
then i had a conversation with them like
hey dude you know no one's allowed to
you know
yeah and it's and it's it's strange i
mean don't get me wrong i'm not
i'm not complaining about it i i like
that i
found that aspect of myself and that it
it really i think it is just
instinctive it becomes a part of like
the animal side of us papa bear
but it's it's strange how radically you
change
and you change your your your priorities
and and how you view everything and like
i used to be because i i'm i'm generally
like i'm i am i'm a people person i like
people
i'm the guy i know it sounds dumb i'm
the guy who when i sit down on a plane
next to a stranger and they start
talking no when they start talking to me
i'm like happy
yeah i'm like oh okay yeah what's your
deal where are you where are you from oh
you're from a different
tell me about [ __ ] nigeria
but i'm so much more cynical of people
now that i have
a child because i all i do is worst case
see see what could potentially be
their negative motives i know you know
so i don't know it's a bummer man
it is a bummer but then like also really
loving
a woman and like having a relationship
where you
take on their well-being where you
really become concerned
that changes me that changed me too like
i i
i even though i only have one child and
she's a dog she's a she's
you guys want more i do
i want more life doesn't it's not that
she doesn't it's just that
my wife's an actress when we had
magnolia my daughter
she was on a series she was undateable
and
um with with uh whitney and everyone
with like uh ron funchess and chris
and brent morin and rick glassman and it
was like it was like
yeah rick rick's amazing i just did his
podcast so rick's rick's a really
interesting dude i love bran i love all
those guys david finn
it was like a great group of dudes and
and and bridget
and gals and stuff but there was like a
set schedule like she knew
okay got picked up for second season she
doesn't have to work till september
let's start [ __ ] and you know what
i'm saying let's start [ __ ] and uh
let's knock it out before you in october
and then you'll be fine and you can lose
the baby weight and get back to work
and then since undateable she's she's
had jobs and it's been great
but there's no stability and my wife
just doesn't know when she can be
30 pounds heavier and now she's 43 and
we've kind of both just
we don't really talk about it but we
kind of understand it's like okay well i
guess
that's a bummer right and it's a little
bit of a bummer right it's a super cool
i guarantee you
i tell my girl this all the time like
our you know my son's four
the boston seven months now he'll be
eight
and they're cute as [ __ ] i'm like you're
telling me you don't want another one of
these
like boston's so cute and good baby like
you're telling me you don't want another
one of these
here's you don't want another one of
these do you know you have your mind
i there's no more unfair deal
than having kids when it comes to like
the difference between guys and guys oh
my god like it's all her
you it's so much easier for you and i to
be like you sure you don't want another
one
because all i have to do is [ __ ] you and
shoot a load inside of you
and then which is something i would love
to do anyway like that's the extent of
my [ __ ] job
you have to go through hormonal hell you
have to get fat
you have to have a [ __ ] human body
explode you you're also gonna be sick
for about nine months and
hate everything do you think corona is
bad why don't you try getting pregnant
for nine months so
my girl gets super sick so i don't wanna
kill i don't wanna pressure because i
i did step back i was like honestly can
you think can you imagine something more
unfair than just like what we have to do
compared to
still though dude that's life man that's
yeah that's that's that's the way the
big man made us
i tell you we could have 10 of that kid
he's so [ __ ] good you have 10 of them
he's so chill your kids are super cute
man yeah super cute
you're older you're older is gonna you
seriously you need to staple condoms to
his dick because
i would just be so scared he's gonna
like there's just gonna be so many
ladies dripping off that dude he's gonna
be
killing it it's trouble for sure then
boston's just this massive baby
it's hilarious yeah there's nothing
better though man
yeah you're uh you have you have mexican
children don't you yeah half mexican
good isn't that weird yeah that's
fantastic
fantastic especially to decide to be
boxers fantastic oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah hopefully not
hopefully not well i mean it is that's
i mean that's a thing i don't think
people they like to talk
about cultural things like that that are
like evolutionary ideas that are
cultural
but i mean dude that's a thing you can't
deny it out like how many
amazing irish
puerto rican mexicans you know like
there's just sir cuban
there like there's combat athletes that
come from certain places in the world
where it's like
wow there's just thousands of you right
it's like in their dna but like in
mexican like that mexican style boxing
have you ever seen a mexican style who's
super flashy
and and he's kind of floyd mayweather
and like pure defense
no yeah they get booed out of the
goddamn no they literally get clowned
i mean uh like they were i mean at the
beginning of that of the beginning of
canelo's career was like
he's not what we're looking for you know
yeah he had to really prove himself and
someone gave him a chat
i mean and then he's like okay that you
guys like me to march forward and knock
dudes out
check got it i understand that i like
that that old-fashioned like that
mexican style
of stanford you know take take two to
give one just keep playing for it i get
that because it's exciting and it is
it's inspiring because you feel like
it's representative of the heart of the
people
what i don't like and what i what i
[ __ ] hate
is this if you're not
a street guy you're not a real mexican
but like how oscar de la hoya got [ __ ]
on
for his career for being a guy who was
a gold the golden boy he was always
wearing his suit he always [ __ ] oscar
de la hoya
bends over backwards for east east he
bleeds
just because he doesn't have a [ __ ]
you know like like street accent and he
doesn't just
put some high heels on yes because just
because he wears lingerie
but you know who does the butt was it
do that he has the boxing gloves on and
in the high heels was it vargas that
talked that whole [ __ ] going into their
fight where like you're not a real
mexican you're [ __ ]
you're soft and then oscar beat the
brakes off yeah i think it's vargas
i mean dude that's a solid how hot would
she have to be for you to dress up like
i'd love to see her but um i'm a [ __ ]
though i
i would like there's a few drinks i'm
like yeah
a couple million girls that could get me
to wear that i agree yeah whatever they
want
yeah i'm dude you know how blitzed he
was out of his mind on cocaheena oh dude
he was
he was like he was like led zeppelin in
their prime [ __ ] up
i got a story free after the show about
him
after the show yeah i don't wanna air
his laundry i like that i had a personal
story about him
but uh there's there's a like kind of a
second coming uh hopefully he turns into
oscar de la hoya but have you seen ryan
garcia he's the best
but he's also like not your typical
mexican like he's good looking
he's a monster but you know like
you know what i like about ryan is that
the talent's
clearly there i mean i don't i don't
know if that's deniable what i like
about him is that he's got a chip on his
shoulder
he's like oh really i'm just a pretty
boy that's fast i don't i'm not tough
i'm not oh watch this
and he's sitting there he's sitting
there [ __ ] cracking the paul brothers
on on instagram you know just breaking
ribs and [ __ ]
you know he's like crossed over too you
know from pop culture
like youtuber because he's a legit boxer
too yeah he's a [ __ ] monster man
he's a monster it's [ __ ] awesome too
because
you know you realize like that's
there's there's the crossover i mean
there's the the obvious cultural
building of like yes he this fighter
becomes a hero to the puerto rican
community to the mexican community but
but that in turn just because of sheer
numbers
then they become essentially an american
icon i mean what canelo has become is
the biggest
canelo's become in in southern
california texas new mexico
in in places like he's a he's a [ __ ]
icon you know
yeah he you know they showtime asked me
to do my pound for pound list he's
always number one
look at you know he's always number one
have you uh
not switched subjects well he first
thought i mean i can't believe i'm
asking you this have you ever
thought of living somewhere else is this
pandemic made you want to live somewhere
else yeah
this pandemic hasn't done it but really
a lot of you just before life experience
yeah really
but it's hard being in show business to
live somewhere else now it's a little
easier with what we do but
it's tough man i i battle back and forth
like me and my girl
in two weeks go to austin to look at
house she's never been there we go look
because we think about moving there
and then it's like i'm talking to theo
and brian i'll see there's a million
moving parts for me to go there because
it's not like
i just have one show if it's just
showtime just blow the bell i could get
up and go yeah we shoot food trucks from
there we can fly
fighters out there well chin and cat
will figure it out
but it's like i've you know i have king
in the sting i got blood i got fire in
the kit so there's all these moving
pieces
and everyone's down but then when you
look at the logistics of it
it just it just it gets hairy man here's
here and then
my thing is it's like i don't mean to
rip you i'm like is it because
right now it's just like la's on fire
like
la's so extreme yeah but when it's not
on fire it's amazing
here in new york's extreme when it's not
on fire it's amazing the the real
problem with los angeles not southern
california
la the real downside to it is that
the perception is absolutely
not the reality and that you get turned
off
all of us do we get turned off by the
superficial nature of the entertainment
industry and everyone's just worried
about image and not
they're not real substantial people and
there's no culture
and the traffic and the overpopulation
and all this and
that is undoubtedly real and there are
definitely people i mean the
entertainment industry kind of lives and
breathes here
that are just consumed with the industry
they don't really give a [ __ ] about
actual human interaction and they don't
care about people's feelings
but in the 11 million
or so people that live in la county
like like 0.08 percent work in the
[ __ ] entertainment industry
and i always use the laker game as an
example
the first three rows of it at a laker
game they are those douchebags
they are those guys with the sunglasses
on indoors with a chick that's like 45
years younger than them and they did
that but the reality is is there's 18
000
other seats in the lego game and it's
all it's a [ __ ] mechanic
and that's it and and truck drivers and
cops and [ __ ] drivers normal people
and the image that is given is that
all of los angeles is these first three
dummy dudes and by the way
99 of those [ __ ] bags aren't from l.a
no you know everyone every goddamn guy i
talked to in the internet entertainment
industry is like ah
pizza is better in new york where i'm
from oh genji well in boston you go you
can get
you can get yourself a nice [ __ ] hero
sandwich i'm like oh really
that's all you're gonna do is i just
like i'm not mo i'm the worst
i'd be the worst superhero ever because
i'm the least ambitious person
if i had [ __ ] you mine if i was jeff
bezos all i do
is buy a gigantic office building in l.a
and just plaster it with nothing but
dodger [ __ ]
and like like like like mr cartoon
graffiti and everything
just like make it la centric every
[ __ ] [ __ ] who gets off a [ __ ]
plane from
pittsburgh and and florida all over the
country and the first thing they do is
talk about how much
better their hometown is that's all late
i know in reality though
you're you're this much the rest of the
city has this unbelievable vibrant
culture
that is not really looked at it's just
like like 10 years ago
everyone in the world looked at new
jersey as being the dudes on jersey
shore
yeah like that or sopranos like yeah
they they get a bad rap
have you been to jersey ninja jerseys i
don't know that
jersey is one of the most jersey is one
of the most educated places in this
country
it's filled with some of the most nice
thoughtful people in the world and
you're sure there's a bunch of guidos
and a bunch of you know
you know like absolute but again that's
the point 01
the majority of the yeah some of the
best people i know brian daley like
a ton of people live in jersey and uh
you know i
my wife gets really concerned about like
what are we going to do we can't live in
l.a but because of fill in the blank
yeah kids get sticky don't and you're in
venice right
yeah now don't get me wrong venice is
dangerous but i always go like look
there's human shield everywhere mike
fall for the trap don't take the bait
because
you as an actress are surrounded by
this segment of it that
gives it the bad rap you know these
people that are and and i've watched my
wife who's successful
in acting i've watched her get [ __ ]
decimated by people who are just so
callous
like agents and like yeah they're
interesting they're just mean people
they don't care they're not nice people
like
because they don't i don't hear that
that's a stereotype there's there's far
too many people
in politics and in show business that
lose sight of just
basic courtesy and they are not nice
well that's everything mike sports i
mean go have a talk with the
you know i don't know now the
matchmakers they're a lot better but go
have a talk with dana white man or yeah
anyone who runs a business or have these
they have these decisions to make they
just don't they just it's almost like
they don't
view human life the same as others you
know because i think
they're just like on to the next i don't
know it's just what's next and they're
like
they have shark eyes it's just all black
like what how the [ __ ] did you get this
way
i've met with agents here it's the same
way it's like
how you wonder though is there value in
it
in a in a job like being a politician
being being
being being a studio exec maybe there's
there's actual benefits to being a
sociopath well there's a reason why
they're like that
it's just a bummer it's heartbreaking do
you go the nfl even when you get to the
nfl man i mean
you know these coaches it's like what i
don't give a
[ __ ] dude catch the ball next
and you're like oh god or a gm or a head
coach
at the same time you got to understand
like the
even compared to most people who make
[ __ ] tons of money
the pressure and the amount of money
that other people have writing on you in
your performance
i kind of understand where you like
there's probably isn't any room for
for you know concerns about people's
emotions and the guy is not
the guy or a gal is not holding it up on
the field you're gone i mean you kind of
same in hollywood though if a guy
or gal isn't holding it up or if they're
not right for the part then i can be
like yeah you know this [ __ ] they're
just like
next get the [ __ ] out of here yeah that
i mean and that
look it is a meritocracy in that sense
where you know kind of talent dictates
what i don't like about especially
sports is a little bit easier because
sports is black and white it doesn't
matter
if you're best friends with a coach or
if you're a nice guy or if you played
the political game behind the scene
if you don't if your [ __ ] shooting
percentage is 16 you're not gonna make
it in the nba if you if you hit 183 for
three seasons
in the nba major league you're done
acting's all there
is like this thing and i i've talked
about it with so many of my friends with
that you know i
i go just keep your chin up because it's
very frustrating
for someone to really to know not to
think
but to know that there's other things at
play that are preventing you from being
as successful as you want to be
besides hard work and drive like when
you're really driven when you're
hard-working when you devote yourself in
every and there's still
other factors that get in the way that's
really really [ __ ] frustrating and i
know life's not fair
but that sucks at least with you could
be a gigantic [ __ ]
but if you're [ __ ] awesome in sports
no one's stopping you no one's going to
prevent you know and like
let's know the extremes i mean well
acting is a little bit like baseball
where you
you're gonna go about three for ten yeah
if you go three for ten you're [ __ ]
killing it yeah you go about one out of
ten
i i i also really worry about
how like you know what was really
exciting and what made me fall in love
with movies in particular
was that when i was like first getting
to the age where i could appreciate the
idea of artwork and like cinema and
going in like
seeing that there's subtext and that
someone put a lot of effort into making
a piece of art to be observed
i was like 14 15 16. and that was
the mid early to mid 90s and there was
just this explosion
of amazing independent cinema and i'm
starting as like a 12 year old i'm
seeing
reservoir dogs and as i'm graduating
high school i'm watching boogie nights
and stuff and i'm thinking like
oh my god i really appreciate this idea
that people can have
amazing creative feelings and and commit
themselves to it and and present me this
with the way the studios are working now
and now the agencies are getting into
creating content
the utas the wmes now they're like
making their own projects they're just
gonna stack the deck with their own
clients and then everything's packaged
and i feel like the guy or gal who just
has a great idea and
a belief in themselves is getting
skinned getting washed away you know
so that that's what really bugs me about
it but
i do i honestly do believe like there's
a
i'm maybe i'm overly optimistic but i
have a real love affair
with the city of los angeles i know
that's why i'm mastering because i'm
literally i'm on the fence i go
in a week or two to go look at texas as
i'm getting closer i find myself
just like i do you know we wrote a list
pros and cons
and as i'm going through the con
starting to build up leaving la
it mean but my love affair is real and i
do see all the
i always say like new york chicago miami
they are like um an amazing like marvel
comic book movie you know what you're
getting when you go in there and it is
amazing you go and you sit you go to new
york city and you're like
it's going to be amazing statue of
liberty and i'm going to go see central
park and it's going to be over the top
times square is going to blow me away
and you land and you go there you're
like whoa this is the center of
existence so new york city is amazing
at south beach you're like what the [ __ ]
look at all these beautiful people
la is like a film noir you kind of don't
know
you have this idea of what you're gonna
see but you sit down you're like
was that it yeah you got it kind of flat
but then
upon further inspection you see what
goes on in the shadows and you're like
oh
this city has so much to offer it
doesn't blow you away because you like
you go down to like the
walk of fame or something you know if
you're a tourist place you're going to
walk around you're like what the [ __ ]
and then you go to disneyland you're
like okay i guess but when you if you
don't go to like the graffiti walls in
venice if you don't go see like the low
rider
you know the low riders at on whittaker
boulevard yes like the the real
the vibrant blood of the city it's
amazing it's amazing it's better than
anywhere in the whole world the
the culture the the the the modern art
and the and the the street art and the
and the kind of like
the underbelly of los angeles is uh is
beautiful but
it's very hard to see it's not it's not
something that is it doesn't no not
everyone's going to tell you about it
but
and there's there's so many different
spots in california that's just
fan [ __ ] tastic man from venice to
marina santa monica malibu
the palisades it's too far apart though
everything's too far apart in la that
that sucks
that does so it's far apart when the
world's back to normal and there's
traffic yeah like right now it's not
bad like right now anywhere you want to
go it's like you want to go downtown
it's 18 minutes
you want to go to the valley it's 18
minutes everything's 18 minutes like can
you imagine if it's like this all the
time
i i do have that like a severe passion i
i love
i'm mexican i love to drive i love cars
everything fits i love the dodgers i
love the lakers
everything's your favorite you're the
most la guy i know i love it in a good
way meaning like right
la like not not not hollywood la
but i love a lot of places and i've
thought about like
i'd love to live in like midland texas
i'd love to live in nashville
i'd love to live in in you know outside
of just outside of atlanta i know i'd
love to live in in
you know somewhere in the uh like i was
in cleveland i
love cleveland i was uh i was conceived
in cleveland oh yeah
my parents thought that that was where
they're going to live and then like
when my mom was pregnant with me they my
dad got cleveland's dope washington dc
i could live in dc dc dc is great but dc
almost you deal with the same problem my
closest buddy lives in dc
he
if you're not in politics you know so i
i've thought about but i
i just i love i've never really been to
places in america and i'm i'm
i'm admittedly um pollyannish about this
country i'm i'm
i'm openly like super pro-american i
love this country
and maybe it's because i've had the
chance to go to
really shitty places i don't think
enough people who and i'm not saying
there's not
tremendous flaws in how we do things in
this country i'm not saying that there
aren't things that desperately need to
be changed no but i am
taking the dick if you talk [ __ ] about
america if you go to saudi arabia
if you've been there if you go to
[ __ ] uh parts of south america you're
like
oh america is so awesome all right
fight fans this week draftkings is
letting you bet on the big
fight the big fight fight night this
saturday night and then also
not only can you bet on shabazzian vs
bronson saturday night but also
nba is back y'all mba is back
draftkings has brought their expertise
to legal sports benefits legitimate
sportsbook base right here in the us of
a
so you can rest assured that your funds
are totally secure
draftkings america's top rated
sportsbook app is safe secure reliable
you can deposit withdraw your money at
your own convenience
you can oh new users sign up bonus a
thousand bucks
say what shabazzian is a minus 300 stuff
listen i like the
over on rounds i think it's two and a
half and uh for it to go
the distance but you never know
shabazzian is a complete monster
you can stop brunson early on but uh the
safest bet is it goes past two and a
half uh check the odds on that
head to the app right now and check out
all they have to offer including player
props
live betting so much more if sportsbook
is not available yet in your state don't
forget about the draftkings fancy app
for this weekend's golf tournament say
what they're offering a share of 1
million
dollars download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now
use your code fighter when you sign up
for limited time all new users can sign
up and get the bonus of a thousand
dollars that's right
draftking sportsbook has a sign signup
bonus up to 1 000
just enter the code fighter when you
sign up only at draftkings sportsbook
you must be 21 or older
bet on ufc this weekend but the nba been
on major league baseball they got it all
at draftkings you must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana or
pennsylvania only bonus comprised of a
first deposit bonus and first bat match
each
up to 500 deposit bonus requires 25
times playthrough
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling prom
question mark call 100 gambler or in
indiana one
eight zero zero nine with it draftkings
enter code fighter fourhams.com is all
about men's
wellness need help with your hair loss
unless you do
erectile dysfunction yep that's a
problem wake him up you have a cold
interested in mental health or how about
coven 19 home test
that's right him's got you covered
didn't know that right like covid what
yep him's got your code covered man uh
66 percent of men
start to lose their hair by 35 and you
can only save what you have once it's
all gone it's too late
if you look like jeff bezos hymns can't
help you save it right now man
save it thanks to science hair loss can
be optional
hymns connect you to fda approved
products to treat hair loss and they
have thousands of happy customers loving
their results
time at home is opportunity for
self-care hims will connect you to
license profession now uh all you gotta
do is answer a few quick questions for
free
and to see if fda approved products to
treat hair loss are right for you
if approved the products show up to your
door discreet little package right
so you don't got to worry about hair
loss anymore today hymns has given you
their best offer yet if you're not happy
with your results after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund you
got nothing to lose baldies
and right now you guys get your first
visit absolutely
free free free go to forehands.com
f a t k that's fat k that's for hims.com
fat k full refund of price paid
available for the first 90 day supplies
refund requests must be made between 90
and 180 days after product shipment
delivered prescription products
requiring online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine if the prescription
is appropriate restriction supply c
website for
details important safety information i
read an article
maybe six seven years ago i read an
article in new york
times and and i was just like killing i
was i'll never forget i was
at a starbucks this had to be longer
because it was before i met my wife i
was waiting for this girl that i was
meeting in vegas
and i was at a starbucks in one of the
casinos waiting for her to meet me
at this like this and i'm sitting there
like i'm like [ __ ] flipping through
the paper i read all the like
main stories and then i do what i don't
typically do and i just start flipping
through like the
cutesy stories i heard this story about
a
collection of afghani women who are
poets
and all that they do to be able to
continue to have their little poetry
club
because what they're doing
is as women in afghanistan
ground for murder and these girls are
like
yes we feel like it's really worth
risking our lives so that we can have
the ability to write our poems and share
them with each other and i'm like holy
[ __ ] yeah people risk their lives to
write here's
here's the thing though those women when
you say murdered you mean stone
yeah yeah dude it's not like a shot it's
not pretty oh you're writing poems chuck
no no we're gonna
dig six feet and then we're gonna stone
you people are gonna come around they
stone you
they still stone people and then have
you ever like watched any
i've never watched a stoning but i've
watched like little clips on like
when they used to have like al jazeera
americans yes
none of those guys can throw
like they've never played long and
painful and i'm like can we at least
loan
them like a retired randy johnson or
something nolan ryan in that
[ __ ] a girl
standing there tied up and it's like
four days later and they're like
throwing like a [ __ ] can we somewhere
like skipping rocks there's got to be
guys in
minor leagues that aren't going to make
it to the majors that still have like a
98 mile
you know just one good stuff like that
get them out of their misery
ship them over you know but uh you're
really you couldn't you and your wife
couldn't especially with her
work you can't really leave it like it's
not an option like for me it's a bit i'm
not
i'm not a hollywood like i'm not i don't
go on i've gone on
auditions but like you know i'm not
auditioning for movies if the right
offer came i'd you know
it was a shooting but i'm not like
hustling with the auditions or
you know yeah stand up i could do in
austin you know there's there's
there's three or four clubs i go to at
night it's in the center so i could
still tour everywhere
yeah it would suck as far as podcasts
because guests you'd have to fly in
guests all the time which would be a
nightmare
there is look you're gonna miss out on
something because not only
is it like the guests and stuff like
that but imagine not having like the
store
that that is a big deal like having a
home club that good
with com other comics that you really
bond with
everyone's raising their game it's just
like going away from a
jiu jitsu academy where there's a you
know just hundreds of murderers
yeah all black you go you go somewhere
where you're like one of the better
people it
change you're not gonna there's value in
that but at the same time like my wife
even though she is she's hollywood she
likes being an actress
she's from like kind of woodsy
seattle area like and she doesn't i mean
my wife likes
fishing and hunting and like i mean
she's she's she should be down she's not
a very
like traditional snowflakey hollywood
girl yeah doesn't you know and i think
that's honestly why
we kind of clicked is that she um
she doesn't like the idea i i with my
first wife and
this is by the way i want to make it
very clear i'm not talking [ __ ]
by any stretch of the imagination but
um with my first wife like i there were
times when i lost my cool
and i would get really kind of macho and
protective of my
ex-wife and my ex-wife was like what are
you doing like just
take it like tell you down there shake
it down
was not mad at me but there was it was
problematic
i see my wife and she's even
kind of opened up about it like um
when i switch over and i'm not a tough
guy or anything but like something
instinctive kicks in where it's like
um i remember a guy uh
tweeted to me and
plenty of people talk [ __ ] and that's
part of the game
but he was saying something really
derogatory about my wife
and uh i i lost my cool and i went on
this like
lengthy twitter wrote a novel where i
was like i'm gonna find you
like i was turned into [ __ ] liam
neeson and i was like i have skills
i'm gonna find you and i'm gonna [ __ ]
kick your ass you know like yeah
you don't i don't want you to believe
that you can get away like you talk [ __ ]
about how i suck you hate me yeah radio
show
you i don't i i don't want to live in a
place where you think you can get away
with that because i will i'm gonna
he must say something bad something yeah
yeah mine wasn't that bad i wasn't like
she's a
fat pig and she should die it was like
more of um
a low blow it was just like yeah she's
getting old you know you're not as hot
as you used to be now you've got the
crow's feet and all that and i was like
so you think you can casually [ __ ] on my
wife you're you
you're wrong yeah i'm good and my my
current wife she's she's like
good thank you i appreciate it she does
she does it and i think there's a
there's a weird because her dad
was a gnarly dude he's past now but he
escaped
he was a czech uh citizen that escaped
communism in czechoslovakia and then
came to america and became
a doctor so he's not like he's not like
this
yuckity yuck soft he's a very
mathematical calculated angry tough dude
right and um and i think that that was
kind of
that was what her model of manhood was
yeah
and i think she likes a guy's guy she
does she just she digs it i started
crying she's like yeah her
her um ideal hollywood dudes are never
like the the goslings and the
the the you know paul walker's was it
like jason momoa or something
it's it's uh excuse me brendan schaub
and i'll repeat this story again i'm not
a guy's guy man i repeat the story again
i i was talking to a casting director
friend of ours who she said
i need a guy in his mid-30s who can
actually handle himself because we're
doing it and i go
i know the dude uh my friend shaub is
literally a was a heavyweight
professional mma fighter
in the ufc it was creme de la creme and
now he's he's in the entertainment
industry
and my wife from across the room goes
and i think he's sexy
like shut up he's a good little guy and
all but can we [ __ ] tone it down
uh but like yeah like in like like
benicio del toro is like a i'm not oh
and she likes that
she likes a guy yeah she goes i feel we
saw sicario 2 in the theater a couple
years ago and we were leaving she goes
you know what's so hot about him she's
like i really believe he might have
actually killed people in real life oh
wow and got away and i was like she's
all in she's like yeah
i was like you know what you're right i
could easily like if i found out if you
guys found out
right now that breaking news bodies
buried
in [ __ ] kevin costner's house he'd be
like
holy sh if you if about it was like
a irrefutable evidence leads back to
benicio del toro and two murders
okay that makes sense yeah all right
that second one nowhere near is the
first though but he is a stun
the first movie is great oh it's the
music man
it's the [ __ ] music he has uh he has
a movie where he played
he's uh pablo escobar really
yeah look at that i don't know this i
don't you know i've gotten bald what was
it traffic
wasn't he pablo escort in traffic no was
he
no paradise lost yes
now he doesn't look anything like pablo
but that's the movie
he's a goddamn great actor i have no
idea all i know it's about this guy
starts dating
paula escobar's like cousin or niece or
some [ __ ] like that and then pablo hires
him work for him
i guess he looks a little bit like pablo
though that's a good actor man
he's a riveting dude to watch have you
seen brawl
i'm trying to get i'm like an evangelist
for this movie have you seen brawl in
cell block 99
no all right how old is it far it's like
two or three years
far too many people haven't seen this
movie it is
uh vince vaughn [ __ ] awesome
at first glance kind of like what i was
talking about
like it looks like first glance you're
like this is just a it's mur it's
violence porn it's it's like uh looks
like guys from wedding crasher raped a
few chicks he is
it's insanely violent but it is so
thoughtful and beautiful and and well
made especially in the day and age where
every movie has to hit you over the head
with exposition and tell you everything
over and over again and just
has no respect for the audience all
right this movie has so much respect for
the audience and it just provided like a
slow drip of
this character study of this guy but it
is crazy violent
like it is insane is it uh
what's it on cell block thank you it was
on amazon for a while i don't know if
you could stream it but
it's got to be like 99 cents to rent
because it was made for like 10
but it's really the guy who did bone
tomahawk directed it and that's another
film
i love vince vaughn man yeah it's good
[ __ ]
speaking about my wife i gotta run this
by you oh what do you got because
she won't answer me in in
like in a complete way
so it's like a couple years ago i'm on
the couch
and i'm sitting down to watch my wife
make her appearance on curb your
enthusiasm
which was big deal a big deal i mean i
mean it's gonna be one of the greatest
comedies uh you know obviously of all
time and in the industry it's super well
respected it's like
very rare that there's a show that
audiences love
and like people in hollywood love it you
know it's it's critically an all-time
great yeah
don't hear anybody hate on no no how can
you [ __ ] on that show never
um so my wife gets this gig on on curb
your enthusiasm one one
one reoccurring roller coaster just one
time just one episode
but she's like a pivotal member of this
of this episode like a pivotal part so
i sit down to watch it and i'm so
excited because i love
my wife and i love when she works and i
love
curb your enthusiasm so we get into the
to the movie
and we watch and i realize oh my wife is
playing a hooker
okay and nothing wrong with that but
then
i start doing like her imdb in my brain
and i'm like oh my god my wife
has been a sex worker on the big
and small screen five [ __ ] times
you know what that means you know what
that i'm hearing your wife's smoking hot
or
that's what it is there's a lot of hot
girls my wife is very attractive but
she's hot but she also
might have a thing where people
collectively as a whole
look at her and go that's the [ __ ] i'm
looking for
and i go what is it about my wife that
says that she has had so much penis
that and so like i have this weird thing
this weird super you're you know this
your wife's
smoking yes she's my type like i like
that she's
she's my highest she's got a big thick
ass your type you mean
hot mike no but a lot of guys just
muscle my type you know hot hot dude
hot's hot but dudes have types i like
i like jin likes real skinny girls like
yeah like right now he's like
taylor swift tooth yeah like he liked
her when she was like
19. oh you know like you like some like
pumpkin jack like kate upton for
instance everyone is like
kate upton's made and she's obviously i
can objectively see she's attractive
just doesn't do it for me yeah she just
doesn't it's not my thing you know like
the blonde beach blonde with the big
big titties i need like like a like a
kind of
exotic looking brunette with a giant ass
i'm not mad at kid upton
look my type's hot dude would i
would i cut off a finger to [ __ ] her yes
but
you understand like isaac gonzalez i
would like i'd let you [ __ ] in my mouth
right now if i could bring her up too
isa gonzalez e-i-z-a
yeah oh i remember her she's hot she's
super hot
you ever see baby driver like she was
the hot chicken baby she was in
like that's oh my god i've never seen
her before
or the you know the uh what's her name i
think her name's natalie could also
natalie emanuel the the the khaleesis
mixed black
white dude her little assistant yeah i
i'd
let you guys collectively do a vomit
session all over my naked body dude
oh i would let the boys do a [ __ ]
yeah one
wonder hockey
oh my god what are we doing what are we
doing here film multiple [ __ ]
sessions on
look at this woman it's insane dude
and she's a mother of two i think i
think one oh my god
dude i'm with you dude cocky all day you
know that's a great thing honestly and i
i know this sounds this is going to
sound dumb
but like hear me out i think that's what
we're offering big
big big upsides to instagram because
there's so many we can
sit here and bemoan all the downsides to
social media instagram
has been really amazing because it's
done something
that nothing else could do in the
history of
modern western humanity and that is
finally got the message through that
guys don't like super skinny chicks
agree if you see the girls all the girls
on instagram
because look the fashion industry and
and hollywood
for years was the the the ideal look for
women was dictated by women other women
and gay guys and fashion directors and
stuff like they would push it on you and
everyone's like what no
and that kind of i think really did
bleed through i don't want to speak for
women but i think for a lot of young
girls they got that message like
oh i have to be a size zero and and i
need to be thinner i need to be thinner
and then all the guys brand comes along
and it's like and you could have as many
guys as you want tell you no
we prefer a woman 20 pounds overweight
compared to 20 pounds they don't get it
instagram comes along and it's like oh
these girls who have
38 inch hips and and and giant ass and
and you know nice meaty arms
they're getting seven thousand they're
getting 700 million followers
and the girls in a million dick pics oh
for a reason yeah and i get
you get a lot of dick pics you seem like
you'd be big in the gay community
uh i don't know not a ton you know what
you know what i i
i've been like this for about six months
i don't really
i'll post i'm out yeah i post i'm out
i don't want people's opinions because
you're swaying my opinions i don't want
i post i'm out i don't see um when i
when i tell you this i see
no comments i see nothing i post so it's
probably the healthiest way to be
but i i think my logic with that is
think of anybody you ever admired
growing up
right anybody none of them had the
influence of all these
fans or haters changing their
creative dreams or creating whatever
they wanted to do they have all this
input
i got one the other day like i don't
typically
pick where i was like i actually like
wrote the guy back i was like that's
it's really that's really impressive
like that's really something
cat showed me one the other day i don't
know what the guy thinks she was going
to do with it dude
is he [ __ ] a couch so i got a dm
where a guy
took a flush lie he shoved it between
two couch cushions
and he [ __ ] the flashlight but he's
butt but
he's like do you have a t-shirt he had a
t-shirt on and no no pants
oh wait so like tony soprano he kept the
shirt on when he did yeah but he's just
he's like looking at the camera he's
like this and he's just [ __ ] his
flashlight i'm like
what do you do that now this guy i would
also dm him back
that is a giant hog
that is a that's a tomahawk
yeah if you had a steakhouse you'd order
the tomahawk
this thing is long
and thick yes and black i told you he's
a good looking dude
handsome man great great physique now is
he trying to [ __ ] yeah oh
but but he was he was real cool about it
because most gay guys now he's now he's
definitely not a bottom
no and that's that was my problem that's
what i wrote back to him i said sir
first off this is an impossible cut
first off incredible penis incredible
incredible dick good body
i'm so flattered that you find me
attractive
but i gotta be honest i'm not a gay man
and i haven't
ever uh uh experimented and if i'm going
to
take my first dive into anal sex with a
penis
yours is not gonna be my choice because
that would for the viewers
i'm talking here to there
yeah and he's not all the way hard
either that thing's just
he's and he's in a compression shorts
white and he's
wet so you can see this this
panther tail just down to his knee i
mean it is a what a burden
it is an impressive cockatoo you have to
be gay with that [ __ ] because
there's no there's no woman that's
pumped uh i've seen some on black.com
where they're
no no no some of those did they're
getting a paycheck i've talked to some
of those ladies i've i
i've had conversations the ladies don't
like it there's a size of [ __ ] where
it's like this is not enjoy i mean this
is what i'm in
oh severe pain sometimes i'm not even
into i'm just like how's it gonna fit
yeah sometimes i just watch like how are
we gonna do this yeah just
fundamentally how's this gonna fit
anyway and then it's like you're like
what else is inside this poor guy and
how do
how does she it's impossible yeah i like
like like tommy lee would be like the
biggest i'm going
like i would like a tommy back in the
day and the only way we found out or
stevie blue eyes had a nice
full thick [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] i wish
he's pretty yeah you know he's you know
nicole anderson that's there's i'm
saying this isn't
that's a big that gets you somewhere
that there's some benefit to it there's
a big where it's like what do we it's
like it's like the difference between
like
like looking like uh hugh jackman with
buffness and then being
on an ifbb pro where you're like well
that what are we what are we doing here
you gas out going up steps yes too much
you know like i understand wanting to be
a little
more jacked there's a [ __ ] where it's
like a pro bodybuilder yes
you have pro bodybuilders yeah stevie's
is it's nice
it's nice it's nice when did you see it
oh he showed you a lot when you were
here
he did [ __ ] and you and you and cal are
like yeah you should see this guy
because i gotta see it you work in porn
that's fantastic and he goes yes
i work with my lady nicole anderson and
of course now i'm like
the porsche that's your girl and i'm
like what well done
so you're talking about his member and
then i'm thinking i gotta see so i say
i i have to see this sometime and next
thing i know he [ __ ] has an image on
his phone just like right here i'm a
porn star dude it's all yeah he sent me
he goes dude
my first video what do you think and i
was i was like video was he because he
sent me
him playing the guitar because i want to
learn the guitar so send me a video him
playing like the guitar in a bunny suit
and like whatever
he's my first favorite thing like
clicking it you know it's him and his
girl i'm like
well dude i don't know i mean it looks
good i
i have no i mean i've
i have no problem watching my friends
have sex
but because i've had i've done it i've
been uh fortunate or unfortunate enough
to
have sex in the same room i've i've had
uh multiple partner sex with friends of
mine
but i don't want to like it's not like
i'm not you know and i have like these
buddies that'll be like
uh hey want to see a video of me [ __ ]
so and so and i'm like
no no i i gotta fit your girl you know
what i'm saying like
dude dude i mean it's your girl i don't
want to see it dude if you're just
if you're single or doing a thing i'll
check it out
but like stevie's girl he brought her to
him one of my andrea and i'm like
did she have you ever seen her yeah
jesus christ i'm like
and she's in hispanics i'm like dude
porn stars are you going to stand by my
merch
porn stars are too attractive right now
and i i mean that and like i like it
but i'm concerned like how the fragile
eggshell 14 year old boy mind can handle
really attractive girls doing all the
nastiest [ __ ] possible
because this girl's impossibly hot and
in person like what the [ __ ]
because like look you know how hard it
was for you and i to even see a naked
girl
when we were 12 13 14. mission
impossible right
and when you did it was really worth it
and you're like that's it if it's a
porn it was like you you had a friend
doing lookout
because a parent might come over like
you watch spice channel with like
fuzz on it and [ __ ] now you're 12 13
years old
you you don't understand sexuality at
all and everything and you can just
click on
uh hottest girls doing double lane video
yeah i don't know the german goo girls
are you [ __ ] me german
german goo girl and then there's this
whole like
prolapse movement which i'm not a fan of
but it would be
fascinating what do you mean what do i
mean prolapse
i don't know if you can google this jen
i'm afraid you can't put
give you a little example of prolapse uh
this is um
this is a vaginal prolapse
that's where i'm out dude this is a
vaginal anal and cervix prolapse
you'd be super distressed this is a
man's anal prolapse
it's a prolapse it's it's base it's like
they're
they're they're they're pulling oh i
know it's inside out
eating cereal out of another girl's
[ __ ] that's where i'm out dude see
that's the um
are those fruit loops yeah you know
there's i like how he had
he was offended by that i mean charms
i'd be more into it
but the thing is is uh yeah for you for
you
that don't know what prolapse is if
you've ever seen that rick and morty
episode
where uh summer accidentally hits that
machine and she becomes a giant and she
hits it again
and it turns all of her insides outsides
and the mom does it
it's that it's a bad butthole yeah
but just butthole it's disgusting
but there's like a movement now like i
don't think there's a movement there is
nope
i think in your small community there
might be a movement but i'm here to tell
you
there's no movement man can i show i'm
sure it's a fringe community
but can i show you after the show can i
show you girls who are like
yeah lick my [ __ ] pro laps and girl
other girls getting in and like i don't
know you're getting paid
and either way can you they could get
paid to have sex like have a penis go in
one of
their homes no they're doing for shock
value like can you imagine if you're
single hooking up with a girl
she was like lick my prolapse i'm like
are you at your
god damn i wouldn't want you but there's
girls that i call the cops there's girls
oh you're not i gotta call the cops
you're obviously where do you drop
okay let's say it's the it's the hottest
girl you can imagine like it's that girl
from game of thrones oh
where do you draw the line where is it
where you're like i'm it's not worth it
well yeah gotta give me some scenarios
dude because i'm willing to go pretty
far
is it a one-time thing is there a future
is she like i'm hanging around for a
long time for me it's
it for me it's violence were like you
wouldn't choke her
choking i don't consider that by like
like choking where she's in control yeah
i'm like yeah
that's funny like you have a code i'm
talking about like i used to i used to
know this young lady
and she wanted me to do like combos and
i was like yeah i can't do
i told her i was like i can't do this
and i would she would i'd she'd like
pull my hair pull me i'm like okay
that's
that's great and then next thing i know
she's like
harder and i i one time i had like a
handful of her [ __ ] hair
and i was like this is i can't i don't
like this i don't know what else to tell
you is yeah it used to be a problem when
i was fighting the ufc on single
girls would think like oh ufc case right
and they'd want it real rough they'd
like hit me hard i'm like yeah
i'll tell you hate you any harder
assuming there's any real issues here
man
seriously yes i'm be [ __ ] like yeah
i don't know dude it's tough it's tough
that i think i think that's my like it's
like everyone's going everyone's like
but she what if she what if she shoots
her lips i'm fine oh i'm out
i'm like i don't prefer that but i'm
that's if if
natalie emanuel walks in here right now
she goes i'm gonna [ __ ] in your mouth
come out to the bathroom mate and you
can
have it yeah give me a toss i'll be like
all right that's great she goes i just
have to warn you every time i
get penetrated i [ __ ] all over the place
like well really get some [ __ ]
washes i'm like ah that's a bummer it is
a bummer but
i'm not i'm not cold it is a bummer i'm
not stopping
oh well no i definitely stopped visual
creature i'm
out dude that's why i don't understand
the like some obviously but to your
to your point that's the with kids
getting into porn yeah
like if your son is on porn he's 14
brings up
for whatever reason prolapse is in the
top videos of the week yeah and he
clicks on that he's going to think
that's normal standard procedure where
he clicks on goo
german girls he's going to think next
thing you know
you guys got to have you got to have the
girls on on the show
it's the problem man yes you like it
i'll do it
um the problem he here yeah it's a
problem
i wonder i wonder dude because i
definitely like uh
i was so obsessive about having sex with
girls
that i allowed it to completely change
my behavior to completely change my
entire personality says every guy
really yes but but like i was lucky i i
mean i
i really spent a considerable amount of
my youth
engaging in dangerous reckless behavior
that i didn't necessarily want to
engage in but looking back on it i
really don't i'm very lucky i'm very
fortunate and i don't take it for
granted i don't have a lot of regrets
um i i never really like burned bridges
with
with buddies and stuff like told lies
and i you know i i stole some cash every
once in a while for my parents and stuff
i did bad things i feel bad for but
but i i reason with him and i made
amends with these people i have
deep regrets about how i treated girls
when you
and i never i never hands on them and
yelled them just
even even into sobriety even into like
my single days after
after my divorce i you know just just
just
really leading them on into thinking
that there was
much bigger future for us and all just
because like i
just trying to get laid yeah and just
staying out later and going and
and talking up girls and and doing
things and being that guy i was being
that guy
and i'm not saying there's anything
inherently wrong with having sex with a
lot of different girls i think kids can
there's just a way you do it where
you're either
you're a dick you're a [ __ ] boy yeah
you're a [ __ ] boy and i and i don't want
to be that guy i don't want to be no
i i am also the [ __ ] the horniest
grossest guy that
i i am obsessive about hot chicks the
girls that i find attractive
it rules it it completely clouds my
judgment i can't
sit through yoga because i have to leave
and beat off i can't do it
i have to i oh wow i can't know there's
a hottie in the class it's so
which in this neck of the woods it's
impossible it's mission
impossible you can't go without there
being one girl who's got lululemon labia
[ __ ] billboard right in front of your
face
and you're like i used to do yoga in uh
santa monica when i first moved here and
the
instructor was a friend of mine and she
had she was this white girl with an
impossible ass yeah
and she'd wear the tightest spandex it's
like i i can't keep
what are we you know i'll walk into i'll
walk into yoga classes i'll be like what
are we doing and like the
guy or gal that i go with that that has
inevitably invited me i go like i can't
i can't do this no i was doing yoga
there's the gay instructor this dude
and for whatever reason just had it out
for me i was doing it just to loosen up
and feel better
and i was committed and i paid for three
months up front because i
i knew if i paid i'd go and i was going
hot yoga it was 90 minutes i was doing
it three times a week committed to it
and then the guy was just a dick like
you know i don't know i'm not familiar
with yoga and they'd say a pose and
everyone in there has been coming for
years
they know exactly what to do so i would
look around and they're you know it's
yoga and santa [ __ ] so the girls are
impossibly hot and
it's just numbers it's a numbers game
dude so when they would say a move
i would look and you go eyes up front
brendan in front of everyone i'm like
dude i'm not checking him out you
[ __ ] idiot
i don't know all the moves was he
man-bun guy yes
i knew it you know why he hates the idea
of you
he doesn't hate you he doesn't even know
you no but that guy
got someone in the ballpark of shaub
put their foot up that guy's ass a lot
or or he lost his girl
and he had a crush on some [ __ ] cutie
jane
and you came through alpha man came
through
believe that two thousand [ __ ] yards
my senior year and she's like
you just took her back to your iroc z
and knocked it out of the park
and he's sitting there going like what
what am i gonna do with my patchouli and
[ __ ] seitan
yeah i stopped going man yeah i was a
guy that's a big problem with you
because i i really
i really and everyone's like i really
believe in yoga
for for the um the benefits i i think
they're overrated
i think there are a lot of them i do i i
think it's a little overrated
well okay overrated for what because
here's my big thing
it's good for peace of mind i think like
the hot yoga and doing it all the time
you gotta relax a little bit i think
it's
incredibly good as an adjunct to other
things what i have a problem with a good
supplement is that there are too many
people especially young girls
who think that they're going to do yoga
all the time and then have
you know fill in the blank chick's body
you know you know jessica biel or no
they look like gumby they turn to gumby
yeah and and they're that's just not the
case i do think though
that it is incredibly good for
um body body control
is something that especially if you get
very good at lifting weights and and get
some level of hypertrophy
yeah that um you can get lot your your
movements can become dysfunctional
and i do think that that but the problem
with yoga is that it's not it's not an
end all be all
it's it's now people do it three four
times a week the hot yoga for 90 minutes
like go lift the [ __ ] weight dude
the guys who you know like mentally it's
good i think once a week
it cleanses your soul you get your mind
right but it's like
if you're trying to get in shape that
ain't it yeah it's not it's not a great
way to go and i
like i always tell people on mikey likes
you the greatest health and fitness
podcast
i was like you got to be be specific
and be realistic with your goals what i
mean by be specific is
if you want to put on 25 pounds of
muscle yoga
don't go to yoga and then do some
push-ups every other day
if you want if muscle gain is your goal
size and mass
you have to get under heavy weights you
have to also supplement that with high
volume and lower reps
with with or excuse me higher reps with
lower weight you there there is a there
you have to
train for your specificity if you want
to be better at muay thai
do not do the same thing i just told the
guy who wants to gain 20 pounds of
muscle correct you know what i'm saying
if you want to get quicker
faster rotational punches you don't need
to be spending all that time with a
three rep deadlift
be specific with what you want if you
want to loosen up
and you want to get more mobility
throughout your thoracic as a guy and a
lot of women you want to get more
mobility through hips yoga is fantastic
but don't don't look at it as your way
to be
looking like brad pitt in fight club
because that's not [ __ ] ain't happening
you know
on your podcast you have uh guests or is
it just i do yeah i mean
not always but i i typically do and uh i
try to look there's a million podcasts
where about health and fitness where
buff guys and gals talk about reps and
sets and eating
and what they don't talk about is the
steroids and they don't talk about that
i wanted to have like a wellness
podcast that was so i would what i
dreamed of doing was making it a podcast
for the guy or gal who's not really into
exercising but
wants to and can still get something out
of that but yet a professional like mike
cefe could listen to it
and still be like that's a really good
podcast i'm interested so interesting
you know
he knows his [ __ ] exactly someone who's
uh he's he's one of the greatest
natural bodybuilders on the planet yes
and understands human performance
and i want it not i've had him on the
show oh really and i wanted to
make a show that that understand like
there is
this linear thing this this continuum
that you can jump on
that's all about getting better and it's
not just for the guy or gal who's a
beginner and it's not just for the world
class
there's a [ __ ] there's a there's a
team you can jump on and i want to
invite you in
where you get up in the morning and you
say like i am going to commit to making
myself better because
i do not have good genetics i do not
have really anything special
to speak of you're pretty sure dude but
what i will say
is like i have this this is that i spent
a serious amount of my time
waking up in the morning and being
really unhappy
with who i am and i've done a lot of
things to try to change that
and a lot of them weren't successful and
a lot of them really really
when you say unhappy physically
physically emotionally mentally where i
stood professionally where i stood in
the eyes of my family where i stood in
the eyes of my friends where i stood in
the eyes of people that i wanted to
impress
that's a lot i i just i i but physically
you were
unhappy with what were you like because
you were never fat
i was never like a fat but i was always
i always perceived myself to be average
and then when i was
drinking and using those feelings would
go away because i would just
devote myself to being in this kind of
altered state were you shredded when you
were using
no i just was just normal i was just
there
i wasn't by any means if i took my shirt
off you wouldn't there wouldn't be any
negative comments but there certainly
wouldn't be any like
that brad pitt yeah um i feel like if i
did coke or math i'd get pretty shredded
there is a thing like people who have
like like kamara usman or
would be shredded like if you if you're
genetically
if you're genetically that guy like i
definitely i'm not gonna i had a buddy
who was a surf punk and he ate nothing
but taco bell and drank nothing but
alcohol
and he was a tweaker and he was [ __ ]
he just had like he looked like david
beckham he was just like shredding
my buddy he eats whatever the [ __ ] he
wants he's jacked
everyone thinks he's on steroids he's
never touched he don't even take protein
powder
he's just jack city that's and genetic
look here's another thing
i feel like i have to go extreme i gotta
eat just
apples for two years to get started
that's where i'm at
you i have to eat just celery for 70
days you're you're a
you're a bigger version of me that's
really well you and i have very similar
shred
i don't think that's in my dna yeah it
yeah it is it is it's just it's not next
month and it's not
it might be in two years but it is yeah
because i'm the same way
i um when i was in high school all the
other
guys that wanted to get good at football
on the football team we all started
lifting weights when we were like 16 17
some of us
more passionately than others i
always could like make serious
considerable gains in my squat and my
deadlift and
lift heavy weights and put on some
muscle and like i got big broad shoulder
um but if i stopped working out and just
being eating normally the same thing
i started soft and fat i'm not like
whereas i have friends that like
will train though and they'll get
injured and then they don't train for a
while they come back they lose
yeah 23 and they get thinner and yeah
i'm not that guy me neither
but shred has come to me it's just take
it just
takes five years of like real effort but
you're uh
you're measuring your food you know or
or both
both probably the way they get and and
here's another thing
guys and girls out there
i'm telling you this not to [ __ ] sell
anybody out
not to be a dick snitch [ __ ] ass snitch
i'm saying this to make you feel a
little bit better and to get some
understanding talk about those girls and
gals
all the people you see in the movies
oh yeah on the action-based television
show
even those girls yes there is a
huge huge huge percentage of them
that are using drugs now are they are
they walking on a professional
bodybuilding stage are they using
2 000 milligrams of tests and a bunch of
[ __ ] you know d ball and jack
no no but trust me
fill in the blank action star guy who
stars in
the any of the fashion the shmir [ __ ]
expendables they're doing
a lot of anabar a lot of gh and a lot of
tests going around hollywood
and that includes the ladies that have
to get in shape for that big amazing
[ __ ] so
i and they only saw on instagram those
girls like my girl like how did she get
this spot i'm like
a lot of that is her diet and there's
some antibar involved
that being said to you that being said
and our friend my mutual friend mike
selfie is a good example
i also get really upset when whenever
you see someone who has an amazing
physique
you automatically say that guy or gal is
on drugs because let me tell you it's
not fair there is a
a real blood drug tested
bodybuilding and physique uh corporation
they blood test your ass
and if you fail they put you on blast on
the internet
move the mic sophie is a blood-tested
natural guy
and he is as shredded and as jacked as
any human can ever be
yeah he's at 41 years old
so all i'm saying is that but but he's a
it's fair to say though he'd be the
exception yes
and and as you get older it's harder as
you get older it's harder
and i i here's my thing though i don't
get why everyone's so
so quiet about it who gives a [ __ ]
if my agent called me up right now todd
feldman was like hey dude
they want you being the next batman but
you gotta put on 40 pounds of straight
muscle yeah i would call my buddies who
know how to get roids
like dude send me everything i'd have
needles in my ass
less than an hour later i wouldn't care
if it was entertainment tonight
or goddamn alex jones if they go oh
you're using drugs here they're getting
that
kind of condition i'd be like yeah i
used about a thousand milligrams a week
of test i was doing a 2.2 shot
you know of gh i think it would help
people if they knew that those
those people that they look up to were
actually on certain stuff
and that they weren't born like that
it's granted it's all it's still this
what they don't understand you can take
all that [ __ ]
and it's not gonna there's still a ton
of work that goes into it come on
johnny all i gotta say i don't give a
[ __ ] if you use more steroids than
dorian yates in his prime
he did what he did took so much
discipline and
so much [ __ ] hard work i literally
don't care nor should you
it doesn't matter i don't care if he was
a
walking pin cushion for six months to
make that
he it's not this isn't josh brolin
getting ready to be [ __ ]
uh thanos his body was goo his body
was chewed gum and he made it into
a amazing physique and he should be
[ __ ]
really applauded for it yup shut the
[ __ ] up on his twitter
yes he got shred city tread
city no he looks fantastic
let's go some current events sounds good
yeah i think it'd be better if like the
rock and these guys came out
like will smith for ali what would you
do if
rock was like you know when rock's like
oh you know
took a jet here and you know i'm getting
ready for uh
pain and gain it's like and what'd you
do for pain game oh i took
deca d ball 700 you know it'd be like oh
that well here's the
thing about the rock or like arnold the
rock is mid-40s
yeah for sure um genetically gifted
this guy is obviously very genetically
gifted his dad was rocky my idea and he
was jacked and and if you've ever seen
um genetics plays a big role i'll give
you this little story before
to uh to um current events
a lot of people now even if they didn't
know who ronnie coleman was they know
him now because of his recent appearance
on the jre
he's widely considered one of the
greatest bodybuilders of all time
um and he is so she was so
jacked like wait maybe he's the best
he's ronnie's the best
i have a personal story about him too by
the way so anyway there's a there's a
training video that he came out with
when he was at his peak is like 2000 or
something where
and he goes back home to his his family
of origin
and um his mom's cooking him his grits
and his chicken i like to eat 12 ounce
chicken then i
my second meal going to be some grits
and he's got you know he's got that
louisiana thick accent
and his mom's cooking for him he's like
mama showed him that double bicep
and he this is a woman who's never even
seen
a gym yeah okay and she's got like a
sleeve and she just goes like that
she has my arms yeah and so i'm saying
like just sarah do you think she's on
none this is an old southern woman who's
never like oh she look at her like look
at those guns that's a woman
she's nev ronnie says she's never
literally never
looked at a gymnasium i'd like to see
her tested but she's just sitting behind
the counter just like you know making it
jacked and i have questions but no she's
jacked and uh so
genetics genetics is a [ __ ] big she's
okay
all right so real quick okay one time
this is probably 2003 2004. he was still
if he wasn't mr olympia he was going
back and forth with jay at the time
um and he was coming out to pasadena
california to pose to do a
a a guest posing spot okay and i was
living there at the time
and was a personal trainer at gold's gym
in pasadena it was at the very beginning
of my radio career this is what i did to
actually make money because i was i'm
making dirt and radio
um so i was a personal trainer there and
the manager of the of the gym goes dude
going to the airport pick up ronnie
coleman shut the [ __ ] up
ronnie and he goes yeah yeah i'm gonna
go pick up ronnie right now he's doing a
guess posing thing in pasadena he's
gonna train here and he's going to get
he got a hotel
i go [ __ ] yeah so that was on a friday
saturday morning i go back to work out
and ronnie coleman's there and he's got
a like a weight caddy
and he's [ __ ] just like blow it up
yeah buddy
and it's awesome right but it was like
saturday like 11 a.m so there wasn't
that many people there
and i'm just walking around ronnie and
um
we both walk over to the incline
bench you know to do dumbbells and i'm
going to put it up and he's like walking
to it at the same time
as i am and i was like oh dude were you
gonna use this yeah he's all right man
you could use i i need a break i need a
break and he's sitting there he's
sweating balls and he's [ __ ] wipes
his friend hands on italians so i was
like i'm only gonna do like two sets or
something
he's like okay no problem man he sits in
it he's very nice guy
so i do like a warm-up [ __ ] and then i
grab the 85s and i do
overhead shoulder press now again that's
pretty good weight right you know i'm
not trying to
but not world-class but i was like you
know i'm a strong guy
and i was like i'm all done and i go to
put him in he's like you could leave him
there man
i'm like okay no problem and ronnie
coleman casually
walks over to them picks them up with
the
at the slight incline like i left it and
starts [ __ ] curling them
oh my god i've never felt like i've
never felt
like more like this yeah i mean he was
struggling but he was still like yeah
buddy
i'm like just christ i just i just
[ __ ] chill
you ever seen his video where he's doing
like uh the squats
and leg press it's insane but that
what's to him you know hats off to him
but
you know they said nobody trained like
no way left like heavy heavy weight like
him
but now you know he can't walk hips are
[ __ ] up
it's a bummer man tim no totally worth
it
totally what he says yeah oh yeah no one
really talks about jay cutler though
they were both like neck and neck right
he took it from jay and like
he wasn't he's just a really nice guy
like
ronnie yeah yeah
[ __ ] monster he's still huge and
amazing amazing talent and everything
but like ronnie was ronnie like ronnie
had that thing where he was like
and he trained in this dungeon in texas
it was like a five thousand degrees
all these [ __ ] equipment's all shitty
he was like not though yeah
pulling people over for steroids jay's
all like perfect hair like training in
like the global gym so i think there was
less
like less appeal you know yeah my boys
feel heath he
you know he didn't compete this year
still one of the best in the world one
of the best in the world for sure
all right what do you got jim all right
okay
so the other day on his podcast joe
rogan
said something that he usually says
which is he thinks that video games are
a waste of time and that it doesn't add
to any personal development
the biggest video gamer in the world
ninja
came out and he basically said that
there are a lot of
more job opportunities in gaming than
joe brogan would think it's not a waste
of time
and a lot of gamers found that got
really mad at defensive
here's the thing with what the reason
joe says that i don't think joe realizes
you know joe's 52 years old man he's on
the gaming world
but you know video gaming you know guy
kids can do it as a legit career now
you're talking about
there's teams these guys live in houses
uh nba 2k
madden like there's a the gaming world's
so big now people can't make money
but to joe's point you know i don't
think everybody's making
you know how many people play video
games more than anybody playing sports
or doing com
there's so many more video games so your
chance of i think his point is your
chance of making money doing that are
very small
the other thing why joe says video games
are issue because joe was addicted to
the game i think diablo or diablo
maybe it was quite straight addicted to
it where he's playing you know when joe
gets when it's archery or where the [ __ ]
it is
he becomes addicted to it so for him i
remember i'm wasting time
dude joe used to have to do radio
because now with the jre he doesn't have
to but
back in the day you know joe used to
come to kevin and bean quite frequently
and i remember one time this is you know
15 years ago he came in
and he was like telling us off the air i
would never tell stories out of school
but he was like dude
i didn't get any sleep last night i was
up playing whatever game he's like i had
like 25 [ __ ] diet mountain dews and i
i just lost i just played straight
through the night again with joseph what
are you is 51 52 years old he doesn't
to him like it's you when i was a kid i
was making money playing video games for
him
he's like dude it can be a complete
waste of time like you can go
professional in it
but if your goal is to become
a comic a podcaster to your point you
get an actress you gotta
do that muay thai jiu jitsu you gotta do
that here's the thing not
waste ten hours and you gotta to be a
professional gamer you gotta spend ten
hours
that's that's the the real problem i
think and i and i totally agree with joe
on this one
even though i like gaming and i think i
encourage people to do it if that's what
brings them joy
there is a career path to it the problem
is is that with something like
any form of exercise or something like
if you're really into
uh playing the guitar you may never
become ingva malmsteen
but if you spend your free time playing
the guitar there's
a myriad of latent benefits if you you
i'll never be andre galvao but if i
spend an hour and a half a couple times
a week doing jiu jitsu it's going to
benefit my life
build relationships in many ways social
building
pushing past self-imposed limitations
understanding uh
uncomfortable situations there's a goal
if you don't make it a career
spending considerable amount of times uh
playing video games
it's not really going to add much and it
will it can definitely take away 100
that's where i think my thing too is
like if you're spending [ __ ]
10 to 12 hours playing video games when
i was a young man i was trying to meet
girls yeah i was trying to get in shape
it's just it's a dangerous road okay
also joe is 51 or 50
however he is 52 he's 50 years old let's
just say he's 50 plus
joe's 52 years old he doesn't know
[ __ ] video games
he doesn't realize how many people are
making careers and millions and millions
are playing video games and they're
selling out arenas but i did
to his point how many people in this
entire world are playing video games
now think of your chance of making it
professional in video games
you have a better chance doing it
probably make it to the nba then you do
making millions playing video games
learn to code hope i don't get canceled
um
honestly though like i heard from a
reliable source that you can get [ __ ]
playing video games now
because it's like that see there there
he goes he this guy goes here this
who's this who is this ninja oh ninja is
great here you go
ninja goes i just want to add joe rogan
is a gamer he is
he goes hands down the dude loves him
and is pretty well informed on the
competitive side aspect of it
i just believe there's a huge gap of
last five years where the gaming
has catapulted into different uh era and
would love to explain
he's right and joe should definitely
have ninja on ninja's the biggest gamer
but he's right like the past five years
it's gotten
so funny with without the weight [ __ ]
or what the [ __ ] it called twitch
twitch the only thing that makes a huge
difference
a huge tip the only reason i know is
because my former boss pete visalia
at fox sports left fox sports to be the
head of some
gaming like competition team and we met
for lunch and he was telling me he's
like oh these guys are in the house
they're training
they have a chef they have a
nutritionist they work out twice a day
i'm like
what the [ __ ] he's like do they have
uniforms like and he's telling me how
much they get paid i'm like holy
[ __ ] he goes and this is going on all
around dude like it's
it's a legit career path and they did
they did
they must get laid if they're rich and
have private chefs and [ __ ]
maybe because okay then i'm sure that
i'm sure ninja's getting his dick i
don't i don't fault a 15 year old boy
for looking at that life and going i
need to do that that needs to be me
because if i got
here's the problem big money and [ __ ]
for video games they're like yes well
here's the problem now my dad like
you're gonna be a loser you're just
gonna stay in your basement all day and
play video games not get outside
and now if i say it to my son he's like
hey dad ninja makes
60 million dollars a year shut the [ __ ]
up like
don't tell me shut up all right have fun
you know i'd go upstairs
like they have a like antique my dad's
face with hundred dollars after i just
come out
what what else you got um this is a sad
one
regis uh passed away the other day at
the age of 88 he died of natural causes
very peacefully in his sleep
that's cool i'm surprised they didn't
chalk up to corona that's cool though
one of the greatest
ever that's cool i really wanna you know
he's had a great run man
like 88 died peacefully like dude you're
talking about a great
legendary run legend one of the greatest
for sure and and
like it's kind of a lost art what he is
is like now every actor model whatever
just
becomes a host and few people remember
like there was
a time in a place where that was a real
job and it took real skill at doing that
where he wasn't a stand-up he wasn't a
singer he would but you
turned on the camera and you put him in
front and he was there
it was a win it was always a way you
felt like you knew him everyone could
relate to him
you know kind of like johnny carson too
you know he wasn't a comic really but
there's there's something about that man
those guys teach that like
he's something that everyone seems to
gravitate towards have you ever met
anybody who doesn't like regis
i have not never i literally have no one
to ever talk [ __ ] about him
ever never what else you got
got this so um
there is i think you were talking about
a brendan where you're keeping up with
the johnny depp amber
whatever reason listen it's quarantine
i'm bored i get all into this [ __ ] but
carry on
so there were a lot of uh speculations
about elon musk having an affair with
amber heard
towards the end of her marriage with
johnny depp and he's come out said it
isn't true apparently johnny depp said
that he would
cut off elon musk's dick
and elon musk found out he did an
interview with new york times and said
that he's willing to fight
johnny dove you know what listen
elon musk is my lord and savior i love
the guy he's brilliant
my prom now with elon and he flew out
you know
told kanye to become president now he's
offering to fight [ __ ] johnny depp
it's like
now he's had you know it's not enough
that he's a billionaire one of the
smartest guys on the planet he's getting
us to mars and
building his [ __ ] teslas and us but
now he's got a taste of fame
and i feel like he's trying to go for it
he's going for him like oh that bums me
out
yeah famous you don't want your
brilliant minds one thing you don't want
that
it is but it's also it's also kind of um
unavoidable when you're in that
situation i mean i don't i don't think
albert einstein sought it out it's just
some people
have that weird charisma that it factor
and
you know look 20 000 probably no
honestly realistically
a couple dozen a couple dozen developers
are really responsible for getting tesla
cars on the road yes
he's the face of he's the he's the you
know the same thing goes with
equals mc squared i'm sure i'm sure
there was it was a it was this
collective idea
especially in science everything is
built on the backs of people who did it
right before you
um what i want to know is who wins that
fight
elon you think that what has johnny depp
ever done where he's had to fight a
human being
he's not not on film yeah you know
you're not you're not jack
sparrow [ __ ] no you come in with all
those scarves and all your rings
and those jack sparrow tattoo and elon's
going to kick you in your
[ __ ] mouth but i think they're crazy
i think johnny depp is lunatic with
supplements
meaning drugs yeah i think elon's just
from a different planet so
johnny just picks up a ring like a
length of a ring
choker right before he gets in there
just comes in like i still take elon
all right all right and he's big much
bigger elon's a big guy
yeah yeah well yeah i mean that's you
can be well compared to johnny depp
i sat next to him at the uh at a ufc
like pretty close to me i was like i had
no idea he's he's
well over six feet i didn't know that i
don't see either fight six two
johnny depp's like shorter than me now
johnny depp versus jeff
bezos better fight oh i think bezos
[ __ ] them both up bezos is five seven
but bezos is a hard man this is a hard
dude is he you ever seen
shirtless bezos well he's on trt so what
so joe rogan doesn't mean he can't [ __ ]
you up i'm just saying
yeah like both jesus is in good shape
is a hard man like he what he's created
he's not as softy i'll tell you anything
i think he'd [ __ ] up all these people
especially if he was around for trt
is uh steve jobs the anger that that man
had he would
there is an anger but steve jobs strikes
me as a type of guy correct me if i'm
wrong you'd know this a lot better than
i
he does strike me as the type of guy who
gets one good shot in the face and
i can't no no no i don't know
because he's up he could be bill gates
i see bill gates is never getting in the
ring he'd just be like i don't care fine
i think steve jobs has so much hate he's
gonna walk in with a turtleneck and [ __ ]
your world up
he might notice it i could see him take
off the turtleneck
he's like no barefoot he's ready to go
at all times yep barefoot with
what else you guys got brandon you
mentioned this one actor spencer grammer
who's also
kelsey grammer's daughter i didn't know
that kelsey graham's daughter yeah the
voice on rick and morty she's sick
i know right it's pretty and it's super
pretty i had no idea
this came she was in new york and i
think a pizza place right
a little and some crazy dude took out a
knife and
sliced her arm and her buddy's [ __ ]
bat oh my god
she tried to stop the fight so i guess
he was yelling at the workers for not
serving him because he was obviously
drunk or
you know out of it so then she wanted
them to stop fighting and then he ended
up slashing her arm
slash your arm and then the no arrests
have been made
and this is the guy right here friend on
the lord that's him there did a video of
them slashing no just just him outside
it's too short
jesus christ man
we'll hopefully shoot well i'm sure
they're uh should be fine
smoking right i have no idea that's the
voice i think of summer
i want kelsey i want kelsey to go after
this dude and [ __ ] him up
he's big too isn't he yeah
these are two people with kids as you
can tell listen to the frozen soundtrack
is it bad i let my uh four and a half
year old watch rick and morty
no it'd be worse of them be worse if it
was like seven eight year old
because i sometimes i let my kid watch
stuff and i just i know it's not
right but i'm like she doesn't [ __ ]
get a thing it was like a couple years
ago
no yeah my dad yeah yeah tiger be like
what kind of monster is that i'm like
all right well
you're good who's this guy this guy's uh
i guess his name is soyt
you're a vietnamese person you should
know vietnamese is vietnamese guy and
then he's just
kind of going viral for his singing and
this how do you make current events
uh well i saw him pop up i think snoop
dogg or someone
uh posted this but you just hear him
singing he does he does it with numbers
though so
pretty amazing i was like let's see this
guy's left way like immediately like
before i even
knew what he did i was like all right
let's see him head butt some dude and
laos he does beautiful music one two
three four
five six seven and in
10 11 12 13 14
15.
[Music]
i slick right there's some more here
that's all he does is count though
to numbers yeah 2 3 4 5 six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen seventeen
eighteen yeah come on
he sounds good right he actually knows
how to sing does he i don't know is the
pitch good the pitch is
right he might be missing a few teeth up
top he does have some teeth
now well english if there's not a video
of shop doing this by tonight
i don't know you guys check out this
harmony
yeah one two three
four five why don't you say three like
that three
10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 yeah come on
one two she's
she's higher register than him right
yeah do you have one where he shows you
hello his teeth yes okay i'm 32 years
old
i'm from vietnam what's your name how
are you
and i'm fire yep there you go
i have 70
i'll just play a few more these are fine
i'm doing fine i'm six foot
six and 103 pounds i lost all my tea
i had to sell tip to save my parents
i like when he going one two three i
know how many times four
five six say seven eight nine
six seven is he good singing chin
i think he's good i do yeah
i don't know without seeing anything
else though no i mean he this is what
he's known for
when he comes to english maybe that's
all he really like numbers
so he's good at it let me just play a
couple two more
okay this is i think it sounds amazing
so this you know there's people just
collabing with them
is he blowing up he's blowing he's got
over a hundred thousand
followers now so this is the last one
here hello
[Music]
some dope rapper needs to come in right
there oh yes
they will that's god his vibe
i'm down with ted yeah that was great
um okay one two three
and you know that there's like there
hasn't been any immature americans that
have gotten access to him yet because he
hasn't done 69.
if there's one frat bro that got over to
vietnam he'd be like 69
69 all right
oh yeah i don't know what the hell this
is but this is it looks pretty awesome
check this out
he's a kid
[Music]
oh crazy right what the [ __ ] oh this
little kid just keeps coming back
wow that little kid's strong that's
pretty much it i don't know the sickest
villain in like john wick or something
if you use his kid as his weapon he just
came
like if not you guys know i see nacho
libre when they had the one dude who had
like
his monkey friend and he'd [ __ ] fling
each other that would be dope that kid's
core strength is insane
right jesus is crazy do you think it
might be like a little person too
sometimes i think it might be but could
be a little kid yeah
all right it's not a big person
we can establish that yeah um i think
this is the last one that's not a big
deal though but so there was a a
rare blue lobster inside a lobster tank
at red lobster and the workers found out
that it was a blue lobster so they
rescued it
and outside zoo super rare so look at
this
one in every two million holy [ __ ] and
then they just spotted it employees not
some
dumb ass and didn't cook this blue
lobster
damn he's cool looking how'd they figure
out he's blue because it wasn't
red exactly wow
when's that send me on red lobster uh
never
really your boy ordered red lobster last
week because my favorite restaurant
boiling crab they have this special oh
yeah
the boiling crab so good have you ever
had i forget it's the shabang
shrimp yeah
during the pandemic just the past week
they decided to shut down
and i've been jonesing for this [ __ ]
shrimp so i looked up what else is open
red lobster i'm like i haven't had red
lobster in i don't know
20 years [ __ ] older red lobster it
was awful yeah
i've never really like heard good i have
nothing against it i just never really
heard
good things and i grew up in the 626
like with their families and
like if i like the idea of eating
shellfish
you wouldn't even it wouldn't even
happen that you would go
because you go to some place where you
have no [ __ ] clue what
the the facade says you go inside
there's a bunch of dudes chain smoking
and there's no menu and you go what
should i order and your friend goes oh
don't mind that guy and the [ __ ] 17
plates of [ __ ]
[ __ ] comes out and you're like oh okay
yeah all right that's that's all i know
of like fresh
food you know you definitely grew up
around asians yeah
yeah endless you understand me i get it
dude
it's probably second hand smoke like a
[ __ ] endless
red red lobsters you want a bummer red
lobster will bum you out
i wonder my girl's never had it so i was
like you know i had a relaxer and it
came i was like
holy [ __ ] i'm sorry i am so sorry the
shrimp scampi was
i mean ah i feel like throwing up
thinking about it it was awful awful
i like had this weird chasm where i grew
up in a household that my mom always
cooked
and then when i was old enough to be on
my own i was not in a position where
like that [ __ ] was a
so i've never been to like olive garden
i've never been a red lobster i've never
been to any like
of the more like it's been you don't
want you don't want to go there yeah
those are bums nothing against them i
just
you know asian food's the the spot
though for
like seafood yeah they make it really
good that's the most the most
bastardized
cuisines besides japanese i think
sushi's like legitimate japanese cuisine
has become kind of prevalent
in america at least out here but chinese
korean who it's like
what we what most people know of it is
[ __ ]
so far off way off you know like like
like getting
you know orange flavored chicken and
stuff like people like chinese food is
you know chinese food especially is an
amazing cuisine that most people do like
panda express isn't chinese food
but if you if you want any advice on
korean barbecue
chins and korean barbecue's strong
the best i've only been once i went with
chin in seattle yeah that's the problem
though we went to seattle that's not
right it was still pretty good
we gotta go out in la but uh is it it's
not is it open in the pandemic
i think some places are you can get it
to go for sure but then they cook it
already which you don't want yeah
k-town's popping too like getting
getting some good korean barbecue you
should do that that would be fun
seriously is that it guys that's it yeah
mike you're the best brother
we love you man thank you sir thank you
guys
this is the fighter in the mic we're out